[Music]
oh
it's cold and early
[Music]
[Music]
no matter how you talk with me
you never
here
by these feelings
[Applause]
oh
all right guys here we are tangier
island
jake you ready to catch some big fish
it's a beautiful day but it's a little
windy and choppy it doesn't take much to
put a wave over the side and swamp us i
really need to get a sit on top kayak
for this sort of thing
it's all my to-do list
you see all these houses sitting here on
the dock these are little peeler sheds
when you catch a crab that's about to
molt you put them in the shed with a
bunch of water and he sheds and becomes
a peeler a soft little gummy crab that
you can eat whole and they're worth a
lot more money so this is where they
make the peeler crabs more peeler crabs
come out of tangier island than just
anybody anywhere else
we got about 12 to 15 mile per hour
winds right in our face and we got
actually decent little waves makes me a
little nervous we might swamp the kayak
because this is not a saltwater kayak
but i've got an ace up my sleeve
i think
yeah we're only in 24 inches of water so
even jacob could walk back to the dock
if we had to so it's uh
not exactly dangerous
but just more of a wrong tool for the
job situation
we're finally turning around the island
but now we've got to go a little bit of
an angle to the waves we're gonna see
how that goes
all right we got a beach we gotta try to
make it to that
oh
oh that was a lot of work
yeah you were wet aren't you
oh i'm dying
i'm paddling for about an hour really
hard to get to this island but we're
only about halfway to where we need to
be but i can't fight this wind and tide
anymore
so we're going to drag the boat along
the beach
to where we want to camp my arms need a
break i'm beat
this is not easy but it's a lot easier
than kayaking in that i got an old crab
trap
hey look at this
you know where it is look at this
it's a chair
we found this last time
look
it's a shark
look at that
it's a dead shark that is that crazy
jacob's been talking about catching a
shark for days that's what he wants to
do more than anything else
ah poop
i think we ran out of beach we gotta get
back in the kayak
why do i have the feeling i'm about to
get really wet
oh poor jacob well i'm wet from the
knees down
but i think jacob got the worst event
you went jacob
yeah
all right guys i need to put the camera
down and fight some wind and current
here
all right i think we found our spot
it's about an hour before high tide so
real estate is a little bit scarce
got to find a spot to set the tent so we
need to find the highest spot we can to
pitch our tent
this might work
but darn it it's close
check this out this is kind of sad
check out this grape
a year ago it was in so much better
shape this used to be an inhabited
island but the erosion's been so bad
that all the houses and everything is
gone now and there's just a few
artifacts left here on tangier island
families bury their loved ones in their
front yard because there's there's
nowhere else to put them
so this is someone's house every once in
a while locals come and move the
gravestones away from the shoreline but
you know what the saying is you can't
fight the tide
oh look at this
last year there was a set of gravestones
right here and you could read them
really well i actually did some research
and found out some interesting things
about the people that were buried here
but after a hundred years of resting in
peace
it's gone
yeah the shoreline's eroded away a lot
too
the beach was a lot wider this time last
year well luckily this is the highest
tide we're going to experience on this
campout so as long as we stay dry in the
next hour we'll be dry all night my
little camping buddies wet cold and
tired i better get the tent up and get
him taken care of
you know i think the tent's gonna be
okay as long as it stays dry in the next
hour
i'm just worried about one rogue wave
coming in and getting everything wet
well now that i got the tent set up i'm
gonna try and see if we get some of our
clothes dried
there we go
got a dairy rigged a little bit
hopefully that does
something poor little guys tuckered
right out
oh that tent's already the perfect
temperature jacob's just snoozing away
i'm gonna let him get his rest and i'm
gonna go bring up the fishing gear this
is an old dayawa surf rod i bought it in
hong kong they don't sell it here in the
u.s and i absolutely love it
telescope's out about 12 feet it's
perfect for this type of thing
this over here is a european carp
fishing rod and reel
it's a taiwan mission x with the fox eos
bite and run reel
great for catching carp but also an
awesome surf fishing rod
surf fishing is not rocket science i'm
taking a pre-packaged rig
chucking it out over a oyster bed at
high tide using a little shrimp as bait
if they're there i'll catch him if not i
won't
whoa
that didn't take long
got something good on here
only been fishing for two minutes and
already got an awesome keeper bass
unfortunately the season doesn't open
until next week so uh we're putting it
back
a fish like that is never swimming by
itself this rod is going to get slammed
i'm getting all these little nibbles
must be like little spot or something
striped bass don't nibble like that
little spot make good bait so i always
keep a couple of these number 12 size
eagle claws in my bag
i'm gonna go check one of those out
there try to catch these little fish
that are stealing my bait and use them
for bait
you know squid is so tough i just use it
like a bait stop
use that to help keep my bait from
sliding off the hook
oh
got a serious fish
oh
there you got hung up
we don't take the kayak out and see if
we can't undo it
ah my butt's nice and wet
easier to paddle without jacob and the
gear
well whatever it was lost it now we'll
throw it back in and see if we can't
catch something i think the wind and the
waves might be calming down a little bit
well i'm nice and wet now
oh we got a real one oh
that was a nice fish oh oh
see the end of my lines all curly and
crimped means my knot was bad that's on
me
there you go that's a beautiful bait
it's exactly what we want
another little bait stealer
look at this
i got a blow toad is a puffer fish or we
call them blow toads when jacob was just
a baby i did a catch and cook video
about blow toads
and uh i got the video all done and
jacob grabbed my external hard drive off
the kitchen table and threw it
and uh broke it and i lost all my
footage but i'm gonna keep this guy this
guy's good eating
i've got a live well going on in here
hey jacob you want to come fish with me
well i am having a ball but i need to
get this little boy some lunch
[Music]
making a little wind block so the flame
doesn't get blown away
did you test that
too hot there we go we got two chunks of
pin fish on a high-low rig we're gonna
see what that catches we might catch a
shark
oh yeah that's bone dry
that worked really well i think we need
to have a campfire tonight so we're
gonna make a little fire pit and get
some firewood together
let's put it right there okay
careful
yeah it's a stingray
see look at that
that's their stinger right there see
look at that
that thing is ferocious it's huge
watch out watch out you can get you in
the footages
[Music]
not a shark but a member of the shark
family so you know there's that
oh i just lost another lead i brought
six of them but i'm down to only two
after three hours the fishing's awesome
though
man i've been getting big hits
i just got another rig hung up i gotta
go get it i can't afford to lose any
more leads
i went and got this rig unstuck and then
the other rod just went off something
big grabbed it and so jake started
fighting it and i kayaked over and
started handling it
and it broke the line
oh
i've got 20 pound mono on these reels
and it's just too light
i need like 40.
uh i'm down to one lead it's a time to
adapt and overcome so
i'm gonna make
some weight here we use this trick in
off the beach shark fishing
and once you catch a fish or you reel it
in
you'll drag this across the reef it'll
tear it open the sand will dump out and
the plastic bag comes back to shore so
you're not littering
but it's a kind of a one-time use weight
all right there we go
nice big chunk of whiting
okay we're gonna put this in the kayak
and take it out
i dropped that bait way out there
i expecting a big old striped bass well
we got some bait soaking and it's
getting late i think it's time to start
cooking some dinner
i'm gonna build a fire right here on the
beach and uh we're gonna see about
cooking up some tacos
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
all right it's time to cook some tacos
all right we call these blow toads but
they're a type of puffer fish super easy
to clean
there we go
nice little chunk of puffer fish it's
kind of like a chicken drumstick
really good tasting meat super easy to
clean you know it takes 10-15 minutes to
clean like 30 of these yeah i mean you
can get really fast at it
well i wanted to do seafood tacos but i
didn't know what if anything i would
catch today so i kind of brought a lot
of stuff
one they had a sale on live lobsters so
i got a lobster and then of course we
got our bait which is perfectly good
fresh shrimp it's refrigerated
and then i've got our click bait these
are freshwater crayfish from thailand
look at these suckers
isn't that crazy
they had them on sale next to the tiger
prawns so i just had to buy a few you
know just because i i've never seen one
before hey jake you want to eat one of
these yeah
okay i'm just gonna take this and remove
this
yeah i got big old green peppers
[Applause]
[Music]
all right jake hold it with your hands
right yeah here wipe your hands on your
shirt get all the sand off
you like it
okay
oh that looks good oh
oh that's good
that's really good
gotta lean over here though i don't want
you eating on my drinking that on my
sleep there you go it's a shrimp
popsicle
huh
all right now we're gonna make a taco
with the puffer fish
there we go puffer fish taco
all right good
[Applause]
you want to eat the lobster
yeah
big old buttery garlicky lobster tail
we got a bag of marshmallows what do you
want chocolate strawberry vanilla or
sour apple
whoa
there we go
go roast that bad boy
that is a great beach fire oh
there you go
well we ate a ton of food and sat by the
fire and counted stars and it's just
been
wonderful but it's super late and i
gotta get to bed i'll see you guys in
the morning
do you sleep well last night
you had your blankie and your survival
shark
oh that's gorgeous
let's make some breakfast all right
we're gonna have breakfast rice
with our our water is all gone our water
leaked
oh
we just lost about a third a gallon of
water luckily
i have a backup i used frozen water
bottles for the cooler
and uh that'll be our drinking water and
cooking water today
all right well that's cooking i think
i'm gonna do some fishing there we go
our very last fishing lead
[Music]
yo it's hot still
there you go
i really enjoy breakfast rice it's kind
of like a mix between rice pudding and
oatmeal but when i lived in japan the
japanese people found it so disgusting
people be like what have you done to
that rice
well lost my last rig so i guess it's
time to call it and get packed up and
head back to the main island
well without all the water food and fuel
we used up we're about 20 30 pounds
lighter and the wind and the waves are
much better today so we should have an
easier time of it
we got some swells but at least they're
not breaking over the boat that's what
matters and we're going to paddle with
the wind and tide to our back that's
going to be very nice
we're shucking around pretty good
we got turned a little sideways and had
a good sized wave come over the side
ah now my butt's wet
yeah you got that
now your fat dad is going to try to get
out
we made it back to tangier and we got
about an hour or so before the ferry
arrives so we're gonna go see about
grabbing some food and
wait for mama and uh company to come
yeah
let's see it's a little early
there's only a couple restaurants on the
island they don't open till 11 so we're
gonna go to the grocery store here get
jacob the snack
okay let's see if they got anything
right here we go you want that
yeah all right
there's no cars on tangier island so
everyone rides utvs and golf carts and
bicycles and stuff
well the fairy should be arriving any
moment now so we're gonna go get some
pizza and ice cream and uh go and meet
mama and the boys at the dock
thank you very much
hey jake
look at that
that is a big piece for a little boy
you got that
there's the boat that's mama's on there
hey tommy
hey
come here bud
ah
hey look jake's got some ice cream and
pizza for you
too
hey dad how are you guys doing good do
you have a good
yeah worked out real well hey dad
all right guys we're just grabbing a
quick tour real quick and uh that'll
also help us get to the beach a little
bit faster and there's small bedding
breakfast
and this
is one of the highest points on earth
island
and we'll meet you back here at 210.
okay well tangier's just a small little
island that can walk the whole thing in
about 45 minutes or so but despite that
it's still nice not to have to walk it
getting old
yeah you see the crabs
oh i am tired sitting down on a beach
eating pizza sounds
wonderful
well guys i hope you enjoyed this video
if you guys want to see more camping
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel check out our camping adventure
playlist we have over 50 camping
adventures posted on that playlist and
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]